In two weeks, it's going to be the 20th anniversary of the assassination of the Prime Minister of Israel, Yitzhak Rabin. This was a shocking event in Israel-- basically, their Kennedy assassination. Rabin had been in the middle of working through a peace deal with the Palestinians. You may remember a famous picture of him and Yasser Arafat outside the White House, with President Clinton kind of awkwardly nudging them both to shake hands.
两周后，就是以色列总理伊扎克·拉宾遇刺20周年。这在以色列是一起令人震惊的事件——基本上相当于他们的“肯尼迪遇刺案”。拉宾当时正在推进与巴勒斯坦人的和平协议。你可能还记得那张著名的照片，他和亚西尔·阿拉法特站在白宫外，克林顿总统有些尴尬地推着他们两人握手。
Two brothers were convicted in the murder-- Israelis. Jews. Religious Jews. The one who pulled the trigger is still in prison, but the other got out a few years ago. His name's Hagai. Hagai and his brother are still unapologetic about what they did. They killed the prime minister because they didn't like his peace deal.
两名以色列兄弟因这起谋杀案被判刑。他们是犹太人，虔诚的犹太教徒。扣动扳机的那个人仍在狱中，但另一个几年前出狱了。他叫哈盖。哈盖和他的兄弟至今对自己所做的事情毫无悔意。他们杀害总理是因为不喜欢他的和平协议。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
"We wanted to do it," he's saying. "Didn't happen by accident."
“我们想这么做，”他说。“这不是意外。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
"We did it to save Jews, to stop this process that was killing Jews." Hagai talked to one of our producers, Nancy Updike, and to another journalist, Dan Ephron, who's also her husband. He's the former Jerusalem bureau chief for Newsweek . They have both reported in Israel for years. Dan and Nancy now join me in studio. Hi, guys.
“我们这样做是为了拯救犹太人，为了阻止这个正在杀死犹太人的进程。”哈盖接受了我们制作人南希·厄普代克和另一位记者丹·埃夫隆的采访，丹也是南希的丈夫。他曾担任《新闻周刊》耶路撒冷分社社长。他们两人在以色列报道多年。丹和南希现在加入演播室。你们好。
Hello.
你好。
Hi, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
So, where was this interview?
那么，这次采访是在哪里进行的？
We visited him at his house, the one he grew up in. It's a small house on a quiet street. He's back there living at home with his parents. It's the same house where Hagai and his brother spent hours together discussing the murder, plotting it in their room up on the second floor.
我们拜访了他成长的房子。这是一条安静街道上的小房子。他回到那里和父母住在一起。就是在那所房子里，哈盖和他的兄弟花了几小时讨论谋杀细节，并在二楼的房间里策划了这一切。
And we got there and we asked him to give us a tour and we ended up around back, in the backyard. And Dan-- I call him Danny-- speaks Hebrew, so he was translating. We're all talking quietly. It's late at night.
我们到了那里，请他带我们参观，最后我们来到了后院。丹——我叫他丹尼——会说希伯来语，所以他负责翻译。我们都在安静地交谈。夜已经很深了。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
This is where he hid some of the ammunition that night, before the police came.
这就是他那天晚上在警察到来之前藏匿部分弹药的地方。
So, the ammunition he's talking about-- Hagai and his brother had stockpiled weapons before the assassination. Hagai made some of the munitions himself. He's a tinkerer.
所以，他说的弹药——哈盖和他的兄弟在暗杀前囤积了武器。哈盖自己制造了一些弹药。他是个爱摆弄东西的人。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. And he was completely open about it. He was kind of proud about it. And he had given us this tour, and as he did, he said, "Look, I hid the weapons from the police over here in the chicken coop, in a bag."
是的。他对此完全公开，甚至感到有些自豪。他带着我们参观时说：“看，我把武器藏在这里的鸡窝里，装在一个袋子里，避开警察。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
"It was a bag. I had built little homemade grenades."
“那是个袋子。我制造了一些自制的简易手榴弹。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
"Part of the silencer that I was working on."
“这是我正在制作的消音器的一部分。”
How long does it take to make a grenade?
制造一个手榴弹需要多久？
Ah. [SPEAKING HEBREW]
啊。[希伯来语发言]
"You have to think a lot before you make it."
“在制作之前你必须多思考。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
"You can make one in an hour, but you have to plan it."
“你可以在一小时内制造一个，但你必须先计划好。”
Hagai took us over to a little prefab shed in a corner of the backyard. It was full of tools and boxes of bolts and wing nuts and all that. And this is the shed where he'd spent months experimenting with and perfecting a kind of bullet that was found in his brother's gun the night of the murder.
哈盖带我们去后院角落的一个预制小屋。里面装满了工具和成盒的螺栓、翼形螺母等等。就是在这个小屋里，他花了几个月时间试验并完善了一种子弹，这种子弹在谋杀当晚在他兄弟的枪里被发现。
This is the exact bullet mold that you used?
这是你使用的那个确切的子弹模具吗？
Ken.
Ken。
OK, so "ken" means "yes" in Hebrew. That's one of the few Hebrew words I remember from Hebrew school.
好的，所以“ken”在希伯来语里是“是”的意思。这是我从希伯来学校学到的为数不多的几个希伯来词之一。
Right, right. And he's showing us this bar of metal that can fit a bunch of bullets in it, and then a second bar fits on top of it and it kind of clamps on top.
对，对。他给我们展示了这根可以容纳一串子弹的金属棒，然后第二根棒子盖在上面，把它夹紧。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
He used all this gear to drill into these bullets and drop a ball bearing inside.
他利用这些装备钻入这些子弹，并在里面放入一颗钢珠。
And I asked Hagai, "What's the ball bearing for?" And he said, "Ah, that was our project. That was our innovation."
我问哈盖：“钢珠是用来做什么的？”他说：“啊，那是我们的项目。那是我们的创新。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
The ball bearing-- the bullet-- so the idea was, that this would penetrate a vest.
钢珠——子弹——所以想法是，它能穿透防弹背心。
A bulletpoof vest.
防弹背心。
A  bulletproof vest. And the way it does it is that the bullet itself would lodge in the vest, but the ball bearing would continue through it. And it was-- it's hard enough and deadly enough to kill-- just the ball bearing, once it penetrated, to kill him.
防弹背心。其原理是子弹本身会卡在背心里，但钢珠会继续穿透。它足够坚硬，足够致命，即便只是钢珠穿透，也足以杀人。
I mean, so-- I mean, did you-- did you make this mold in order to make the bullets for that purpose, to shoot Rabin?
我的意思是，你制造这个模具是为了制造子弹来实现这个目的吗，为了枪杀拉宾？
Um. [SPEAKING HEBREW]
嗯。[希伯来语发言]
"I think you could say yes. The answer is yes."
“我想你可以说是。答案是肯定的。”
So, this was the exact equipment he used to modify the bullets to kill the Prime Minister, and he's happy to show it to us. And because he and his brother both had this attitude-- they were both proud of what they'd done-- as a murder case, this assassination was open and shut. The shooter, Hagai's brother, his name is Yigal Amir. He was grabbed right on the spot. The bullets matched his gun. There were several witnesses within a few feet of the shooter when he pulled the trigger. There was an amateur film that captured key parts of the scene. The killer confessed immediately, in detail. He reenacted the incident with police-- that's on video too. And he's never expressed remorse. He's never recanted any part of his confession.
所以，这就是他用来改装子弹以刺杀总理的确切设备，他很乐意向我们展示。正因为他和他的兄弟都有这种态度——他们都为自己所做的事感到自豪——作为一个谋杀案，这场暗杀是一起清清楚楚的案子。枪手，即哈盖的兄弟，名叫伊加尔·阿米尔。他当场被抓获。子弹与他的枪支相吻合。枪手扣动扳机时，周围几英尺内有几名目击者。还有一部业余电影捕捉到了现场的关键部分。凶手立即供认不讳，细节翔实。他还与警方重演了事件过程——这也录了像。他从不表示悔恨。他从未推翻过供词的任何部分。
OK, but-- I can feel the "but" that you're about to say.
好的，但是——我能感觉到你即将说出的那个“但是”。
Right. There is a "but." So, in spite of all this, in spite of all the evidence, lots of people don't believe it's true. They don't believe that Yigal Amir and his brother killed Rabin.
没错。确实有一个“但是”。尽管有这一切，尽管有所有证据，还是有很多人不相信这是事实。他们不相信伊加尔·阿米尔和他兄弟杀害了拉宾。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
That's enough? He says, "Yigal Amir did not murder Rabin." I said, "Who did?" He said the Shabak did.
这还不够吗？他说：“伊加尔·阿米尔没有谋杀拉宾。”我说：“那是谁干的？”他说是辛贝特干的。
The Shabak is like the Israeli equivalent of the FBI, plus they have a bodyguard division. So it's sort of a combination of the FBI and the Secret Service.
辛贝特（Shabak）就像以色列版的FBI，外加保镖部门。所以它某种程度上是FBI和特勤局的结合体。
So even though there's all this evidence that could not seem, like, more clear-- there's witnesses, there's video, there's a confession-- there are conspiracy theories?
所以，尽管有所有看起来再清楚不过的证据——有证人、有视频、有口供——还是存在阴谋论？
Yeah. And they're popular. These are just random people on the street in Jerusalem one night this past summer.
是的。而且很流行。这些只是今年夏天某个晚上在耶路撒冷街头随机采访的路人。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
So he says that it was the Shabak that killed Rabin. He knows that because the bullets were in the front and Yigal Amir had shot from behind.
他说就是辛贝特杀了拉宾。他知道这一点是因为子弹是从前面射入的，而伊加尔·阿米尔是从背后射击的。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
OK, so what she's saying is, "I'm absolutely not sure that Amir actually killed Rabin. There were all kinds of machinations, all kinds of intrigue going on at the time, and maybe the state was involved."
好的，她说的是：“我完全不确定阿米尔是否真的杀害了拉宾。当时有各种阴谋，各种权术，也许国家也参与其中。”
So, according to polls, fully a third of Israelis doubt that Yigal Amir pulled the trigger. They think there was a conspiracy or a major cover up. Among Israelis who identify as right wing, the doubters number at least 50%.
根据民意调查，整整三分之一的以色列人怀疑伊加尔·阿米尔扣动了扳机。他们认为存在阴谋或大规模掩盖行为。在自认为是右翼的以色列人中，怀疑者至少占50%。
50? Five-oh?
50？五零？
50, yeah. It's a big number.
50，是的。这是一个很大的数字。
And I've been researching and reporting on the assassination for several years now. And as I got deeper, I felt like I was in this weird loop where, on the one hand, all the documents I had read and all the people who were there that I spoke to-- police investigators, bodyguards, witnesses-- all that pointed to the fact that Yigal Amir killed the prime minister. And then alongside that, sometimes in interviews or conversations with Israelis, I'd get this look like, "You really believe that?" And I just wanted to understand why. Why are the conspiracy theories plausible to so much of the country?
我研究和报道这起暗杀事件已经有好几年了。随着深入了解，我感觉自己陷入了一个奇怪的循环：一方面，我阅读的所有文件和采访过的所有在场人员——警察调查员、保镖、证人——都指向伊加尔·阿米尔杀害了总理这一事实。另一方面，在采访或与以色列人交谈时，我经常看到一种眼神，好像在说：“你真的相信吗？”我只是想弄明白为什么。为什么阴谋论对这个国家如此多人来说是可信的？
And the fact that this assassination is seen so differently by different people in Israel has real implications for politics there today, right now.
事实上，这起暗杀事件在以色列被不同的人以如此不同的方式看待，这对当今的政治有着现实的影响。
Well, from WBEZ it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We hear so much about Israel here in our country, and I should say, over the months that we have worked on today's program, it has made me understand things about Israel that I never understood before. Rabin's death is a very helpful prism to understand Israel and Israelis today-- even the news these last few weeks, this new round of violence. Rabin was assassinated in the middle of a peace deal that the United States had thrown all of its weight behind. Every president since then has tried and failed to broker peace. Today on our program, we're telling the story of what happened that night that Rabin was killed and we're telling the story of how Israelis see that moment today and what that tells us about Israel, Israeli politics, and the chances for peace. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们在国内听到了很多关于以色列的信息，我得说，在制作今天节目的几个月里，它让我理解了一些以前从未理解的关于以色列的事情。拉宾之死是理解当今以色列和以色列人的一个非常有用的视角——甚至是最近几周的新闻，新一轮的暴力事件。拉宾在得到美国全力支持的和平协议期间被暗杀。此后的每一位总统都试图调解和平，但都失败了。今天，我们要讲述拉宾遇害那天晚上发生的故事，讲述以色列人今天如何看待那个时刻，以及这告诉了我们关于以色列、以色列政治和和平机会的什么。请继续收听。
And with that, I hand things over to Nancy and Dan.
接下来，我交给南希和丹。
Here's what happened the night of the assassination. Rabin was speaking at a political rally, and I actually attended that rally. I was a young reporter covering the event. Later, I covered the murder trial. And the rally was huge-- there were speeches and songs. More than 100,000 people showed up. They filled the main plaza in Tel Aviv and packed the side streets. Most of them were left wing or center left, like Rabin. He was the head of the Labor Party.
这就是暗杀之夜发生的事情。拉宾当时正在政治集会上发言，我实际上参加了那次集会。我当时是一名报道该事件的年轻记者。后来，我报道了谋杀案的审判。那次集会规模巨大——有演讲和歌曲。超过10万人到场。他们挤满了特拉维夫的主要广场，占满了旁边的街道。他们中的大多数人是左翼或中左翼，就像拉宾一样。他是工党的领导人。
So the slogan of the rally was, "Yes to peace, no to violence." And turnout was important, because the point of the rally had been to gauge how much support Rabin had for the peace deals he was pursuing with the Palestinians-- they're called the Oslo Accords. And here's what Oslo called for-- for Israel to gradually withdraw from parts of the West Bank and Gaza so that Palestinians could govern themselves.
集会的口号是“支持和平，拒绝暴力”。参与人数非常重要，因为集会的目的是衡量拉宾为推进与巴勒斯坦人的和平协议（即《奥斯陆协议》）所获得的支持度。《奥斯陆协议》要求以色列逐步从约旦河西岸和加沙地带撤离，以便巴勒斯坦人能自治。
And a lot of right-wing Israelis saw Oslo as a terrible thing, as a security threat, and, because it involved giving back land God promised to the Jews, a betrayal of Judaism. They'd been protesting against Oslo and against the Rabin government for months. There was even a small right-wing counterdemonstration that night held near the rally. One of the people at the counterdemo-- and this is in a story I wrote that night-- one of them held up a sign that said, "A rope for the traitors."
许多右翼以色列人认为奥斯陆协议是一件可怕的事情，是对安全的威胁，而且因为它涉及交还上帝承诺给犹太人的土地，是对犹太教的背叛。他们几个月来一直在抗议奥斯陆协议和拉宾政府。那天晚上集会附近甚至有一个小型的右翼反示威。反示威人群中的一个人——这是我当晚写的故事——举着一个牌子，上面写着“给叛徒绳子”。
I've read through dozens of police reports filed on the night of the murder. One that caught my eye was written by Chief Superintendent Moti Naftali. He helped draw up the security plan for the rally, along with the Israeli equivalent of the FBI, the Shabak.
我读过几十份谋杀当晚归档的警察报告。其中一份引起我注意的是由总警司莫蒂·纳夫塔利写的。他协助制定了集会的安全计划，与以色列版的FBI——辛贝特一起。
Here were the Shabak.
辛贝特就在这儿。
Over here on the left?
左边这边？
On the left. And we were here.
在左边。而我们就在这里。
A few months ago, we went with Moti up onto the stage where Rabin stood. It looks out over the plaza where the rally was held. Moti was also on stage the night of the assassination. There was a police command center off to one side. He's pointing out where that was, where other people were. Moti is a pipe smoker, the only one I've ever met in Israel. He also speaks German-- he'll throw in a word of that sometimes. And today is the first time he's come up here since that night 20 years ago. He's not a sentimental man.
几个月前，我们和莫蒂一起去了拉宾站过的舞台上。它俯瞰着举行集会的广场。莫蒂在暗杀之夜也在台上。一侧有一个警察指挥中心。他指出那里是哪里，还有其他人在哪里。莫蒂抽烟斗，这是我在以色列见过的唯一一个抽烟斗的人。他也说德语——有时会夹杂一些德语单词。今天是20年前那个晚上以来他第一次回来这里。他不是一个多愁善感的人。
You know, it's like when I go into my high school. I look ahead. I look forward.
你知道，这就像我回到高中一样。我往前看。我向前看。
The mission for law enforcement that evening of the rally was to maintain order and, of course, to protect the prime minister. Moti remembers preparing for just one scenario.
那天晚上集会的执法任务是维护秩序，当然还有保护总理。莫蒂记得只为一个场景做好了准备。
That the Palestinians, they will commit a terror operation. Nobody in all the work before-- nobody talked about an Israeli or a Jewish assassin. When it was finished, from here, I called my wife and I said, [GERMAN] "Thank God, it's finished."
巴勒斯坦人会发动恐怖袭击。在之前的所有工作中，没有人提到过以色列或犹太刺客。结束后，我从这里给妻子打电话，说[德语]“谢天谢地，结束了。”
"Thank God," in German. Yeah.
“谢天谢地”，德语说的。是的。
[HEBREW] "Nothing happened."
[希伯来语]“什么都没发生。”
It went fine.
一切顺利。
The rally went fine. It ended, Rabin left the stage, and then after Moti called his wife--
集会进行得很顺利。结束后，拉宾离开了舞台，然后莫蒂给妻子打完电话后——
I heard people running and a noise. And I run with them as well.
我听到有人在跑，还有噪音。我也跟着他们跑。
Was it clear that these were shots?
清楚那是枪声吗？
No, no.
没有，没有。
What Moti heard but didn't see was captured on amateur video. There's no TV news footage of the assassination because the rally was over-- the news was over. This moment when the shooting happened was a nothing moment. Just the prime minister, Rabin, walking down the stairs behind the stage and back to his car.
莫蒂听到但没看到的东西被业余视频捕捉到了。没有电视新闻的暗杀镜头，因为集会已经结束了——新闻时间已经过了。枪击发生的这一刻是一个“空窗期”。只有拉宾总理从舞台后面的楼梯走下来回到车里。
In the amateur footage-- we found this copy on YouTube-- we see Rabin's car off to the side with his driver, Menachem Damti, standing next to it. There's a small crowd at the bottom of the stairs as he comes down. People are applauding. They're mostly just a bunch of dark, human-sized shapes. Rabin is pretty easy to spot because he's in the middle and his glasses are glinting. And then one of the shapes who's been sitting off to the side stands up, walks through a few people till he's just behind Rabin, lifts his right arm, and there are flashes and the sound of three gunshots.
在业余录像中——我们在YouTube上找到了这个副本——我们可以看到拉宾的车停在一边，司机梅纳赫姆·达姆蒂站在旁边。当他下来时，楼梯底部有一小群人。人们在鼓掌。他们大多只是一群深色的、人型的阴影。拉宾很容易被认出来，因为他在中间，眼镜在闪光。然后，一个一直坐在旁边的人站了起来，走过几个人，直到他站在拉宾身后，举起右手，出现了闪光，并传出三声枪响。
[GUNSHOTS]
[枪声]
The camera drops, seemingly in shock, and then recovers. All of this has happened only a few feet from the car that Rabin was about to get into. And we see Rabin's driver bend over Rabin and then jump into the driver's seat. The film ends there. Rabin, his bodyguard, and the driver speed off to the hospital. The assassin, Yigal Amir-- the brother of Hagai, who you heard from earlier-- is tackled and taken to police headquarters to be interrogated by Moti Naftali.
摄像机似乎因震惊而跌落，然后又恢复。所有这一切都发生在拉宾即将进入的汽车前几英尺处。我们看到拉宾的司机弯下腰扶住拉宾，然后跳进驾驶座。录像到此结束。拉宾、他的保镖和司机疾驰向医院。刺客，伊加尔·阿米尔——你之前听到的哈盖的兄弟——被扑倒并带到警察总部，接受莫蒂·纳夫塔利的审讯。
Moti was the first person to interrogate Yigal Amir in the hours after the assassination. This was a few blocks away at the Tel Aviv police headquarters.
莫蒂是暗杀事件发生后几小时内第一个审讯伊加尔·阿米尔的人。这发生在离特拉维夫警察总部几个街区的地方。
He was in [HEBREW], we say in Hebrew. How you say in English?
他在[希伯来语]，我们希伯来语这样说。英语怎么说？
Euphoria.
欣快感。
Euphoria. Because he had a mission and he did it.
欣快感。因为他有一个使命，并且完成了它。
There's video of Moti interrogating Amir. The sound quality is terrible in parts of the tape, but it's mesmerizing to watch.
有莫蒂审讯阿米尔的录像。磁带部分地方的音质很差，但观看过程令人着迷。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Amir talks in small bites and he repeats himself, because Moti, sitting across the table from him, is writing down every word by hand. At one point, Amir stops what he's saying to make sure Moti is getting everything down. He says, "Did you write that down?"
阿米尔断断续续地说话，而且他重复自己，因为坐在桌子对面的莫蒂正在手写每一个字。有一次，阿米尔停下来确认莫蒂是否记下了所有内容。他说：“你记下来了吗？”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Ken.
Ken。
Remember, "ken," in Hebrew means "yes."
记住，“ken”在希伯来语里是“是”的意思。
At the start of the interrogation, it's not clear yet that Rabin is dead. Moti is just focused on Amir. Who is this guy? Moti, like the rest of the police in the Shabak, is stunned by the fact that Amir is Jewish, an Israeli, not Palestinian. He finds out he's 25 years old. He's a law student, a devout Jew, and Amir, to him, is just baffling.
在审讯开始时，拉宾是否死亡还不清楚。莫蒂只是专注于阿米尔。这家伙是谁？莫蒂和辛贝特的警察一样，对阿米尔是犹太人、是以色列人而不是巴勒斯坦人感到震惊。他发现他25岁。他是一名法学院学生，一个虔诚的犹太人，对他来说，阿米尔简直令人费解。
I see a guy, normal guy from a good family, student, and a murderer. I, I'm-- I dealed with murderer. They were-- they were criminal. He wasn't criminal. It's the first time that I dealed with the ideological criminal. I say he's a wet dream of every woman, that she will have such a guy for her daughter.
我看到一个家伙，来自好家庭的普通人，学生，却是个杀手。我，我处理过杀手。他们是犯罪分子。他不是罪犯。这是我第一次处理意识形态罪犯。我说他是每个女人梦寐以求的女婿人选。
Sort of the men every woman wants for her son-in-law.
也就是每个女人都想为自己的女儿找的那种人。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He was educated, polite, good manners-- a murderer.
是的，没错。他受过教育，有礼貌，举止得体——却是个杀手。
Amir in the video is calm. He's measured. There's no rambly, incoherent manifesto. He's not even raising his voice. He seems sane. He's just very smug. He says to Moti at one point, "Your questions are an insult to my intelligence."
视频里的阿米尔很冷静。他说话很有分寸。没有零碎、语无伦次的宣言。他甚至没有提高音量。他看起来很清醒。他只是非常自以为是。有一次他对莫蒂说：“你的问题是对我智商的侮辱。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
But Amir is happy to tell him everything. He'd been developing the idea of killing Rabin for two years. He used his own gun, a 9-millimeter Beretta. He'd loaded it with bullets from a fresh box before leaving the house, then he took bus number 247 from his home in Herzliya to the rally.
但阿米尔很乐意告诉他一切。他两年前就开始产生杀害拉宾的想法。他用了自己的枪，一把9毫米伯莱塔。出门前，他从新盒子里装上了子弹，然后乘坐247路公交车从他在赫兹利亚的家去参加集会。
Amir said he'd read the Oslo Accords-- the complete version, not the summary that was in the newspapers-- and he felt it was his obligation to stop Rabin from going ahead with Oslo, his religious duty under Jewish laws known as "din rodef" and "din moser." He said he had to protect the land of Israel. At the rally, Amir told himself that if God wanted him to kill Rabin, he would give him an opportunity to do it, and the opportunity came.
阿米尔说他读过《奥斯陆协议》——完整版，而不是报纸上的摘要——他觉得阻止拉宾继续推进奥斯陆协议是他的义务，是犹太法律下被称为“追击者律”（din rodef）和“告密者律”（din moser）的宗教义务。他说他必须保护以色列的土地。在集会上，阿米尔告诉自己，如果上帝想要他杀死拉宾，就会给他机会，而机会来了。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Moti-- you see this in the video-- he's losing patience. But he wants a full confession, so he remains polite.
莫蒂——你在录像中可以看到——他正在失去耐心。但他想要一份完整的口供，所以他保持礼貌。
One of my police came in and brought me a cup of tea in a kowc, white kowc. You know, this--
我的一名警察走进来，递给我一杯茶，装在白色的泡沫塑料杯里。你知道，这——
Styrofoam cup.
泡沫塑料杯。
Yeah. And I told to him, "Would you also like a cup of tea?" He said yes and I told him, "Bring another one, please," and he brought him the cup of tea. And he says, "Don't you have any cookies?" And I told him, "Oh, you are-- you are pushing your luck."
是的。我问他：“你也要喝杯茶吗？”他说好，我告诉他：“请再拿一杯来。”他给他拿来了那杯茶。然后他说：“没有饼干吗？”我告诉他：“噢，你这是得寸进尺。”
I remember his reaction when I told him-- when I accused him. And I tell him, "I, me, Moti Naftali, accuse you that you shot the prime minister and you caused his death." And he was shocked to hear it. He said, "What? Did he die? Wow!" And he jumped, like your team make a goal.
我记得我指控他时他的反应。我告诉他：“我，莫蒂·纳夫塔利，指控你枪杀了总理，并导致了他的死亡。”他听到这个很震惊。他说：“什么？他死了？哇！”他跳了起来，就像你的球队进球一样。
Like your team scored a goal in a soccer game?
就像你的球队在足球比赛中进球了？
Yeah, yeah. And this moment, you want to come and punch him in the face, but you must be correct. You must sit down. Sit down. "Would you like a cup of tea?" "Let's make l'chaim," he said.
是的。在那一刻，你想上前冲他脸上来一拳，但你必须保持冷静。坐下。坐下。“你想喝杯茶吗？”“让我们碰杯（l'chaim）吧，”他说。
"Let's make a toast."
“让我们干杯。”
Let's make a toast. Yeah.
让我们干杯。是的。
"L'chaim" means "To life!"
“L'chaim”的意思是“致敬生命！”
Yeah.
是的。
To make a toast to life.
为了生命干杯。
Yeah, to life. To life that he took.
是的，为了生命。为了他夺去的生命。
[CROWD CHANTING]
[人群高喊]
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
This is the crowd outside the hospital where Rabin was taken after he was shot. It's from a radio report. I had left the rally before the shooting, along with other journalists, and I got a beeper message-- this was the 90s, a lot of beepers-- saying, "Shot fired near Rabin." So I turned around and ran. I really ran back to the square-- and then from the square to the hospital nearby. I saw this crowd and I heard these shouts. The crowd is furious. You can hear it. They're Rabin supporters and what they're chanting is "Bibi rotzeach," meaning "Bibi is a murderer."
这是拉宾被枪击后送往的医院外面的人群。这是广播报道。我在枪击前就和别的记者离开了集会，然后我收到了寻呼机信息——这是90年代，有很多寻呼机——上面写着“拉宾附近有枪声”。所以我转身跑了回去。我真的跑回了广场——然后从广场跑到附近的医院。我看到了这群人，听到了这些喊声。人群愤怒至极。你能听得出来。他们是拉宾的支持者，他们高喊的是“Bibi rotzeach”，意思是“比比（内塔尼亚胡）是杀人犯”。
Bibi rotzeach!
比比是杀人犯！
Bibi-- and maybe you know this-- is the nickname for Benjamin Netanyahu. He's the Prime Minister of Israel today. At the time, he headed the right-wing opposition, the side opposed to Rabin and to the Oslo deal.
比比——也许你知道——是本雅明·内塔尼亚胡的绰号。他现在是以色列的总理。当时，他领导右翼反对派，即反对拉宾和奥斯陆协议的一方。
Israeli politics is always fierce. I once saw on TV a lawmaker in the Israeli parliament throw a glass of water into another parliament member's face. And in the months before the assassination, the rhetoric against Rabin had been relentless. There were posters with his face in the crosshairs of a gun. There were posters of him dressed as Yasser Arafat, the leader of the PLO, wearing a keffiyeh on his head. A poster of him dressed as a Nazi SS officer. People chanted "murderer" and "traitor" at rallies and outside Rabin's apartment in Tel Aviv. People chanted "Death to Rabin." Palestinian groups who opposed the Oslo accords had killed dozens of Israelis in suicide attacks since the start of the peace process and many Israelis blamed Rabin for those deaths. It was pure rage. The right was enraged at Oslo and at Rabin.
以色列的政治一直很激烈。我曾在电视上看到以色列议会的议员把一杯水泼在另一位议员的脸上。在暗杀前的几个月里，针对拉宾的言论一直没有停止。海报上他的脸被瞄准镜瞄准。有他打扮成巴勒斯坦解放组织领导人亚西尔·阿拉法特，头上戴着库菲亚头巾的海报。有他打扮成纳粹党卫军军官的海报。人们在集会上和拉宾在特拉维夫的住所外高喊“杀人犯”和“叛徒”。人们高喊“拉宾去死”。自和平进程开始以来，反对奥斯陆协议的巴勒斯坦组织已经杀害了数十名以色列人，许多以色列人将这些死亡归咎于拉宾。那是一种纯粹的愤怒。右翼对奥斯陆协议和拉宾感到愤怒。
But the night of the assassination, it was the left that became enraged. The feeling was, one man pulled the trigger, but a much larger group bore the blame for stoking hatred and violence against Rabin. A left-wing slogan would emerge-- "We will not forgive and we will not forget."
但在暗杀之夜，愤怒的是左翼。人们觉得，虽然是一个人扣动了扳机，但更大的一群人对煽动针对拉宾的仇恨和暴力负有责任。一个左翼口号出现了——“我们不会宽恕，我们不会遗忘”。
When Rabin's chief of staff comes out of the hospital to make the announcement that the prime minister is dead, it takes him more than a minute of yelling at people to keep quiet before he can make himself heard.
当拉宾的参谋长从医院出来宣布总理去世时，他花了超过一分钟的时间对着人群大喊保持安静，之后才能让别人听到他的话。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
By now, the country's chief pathologist, Professor Yehuda Hiss, heads to the hospital to perform the autopsy.
到目前为止，国家的首席病理学家叶胡达·希斯教授前往医院进行尸检。
Look, I was raised on the investigation into the death of President Kennedy.
看，我是听着肯尼迪总统死亡调查长大的。
"Into the death of President Kennedy." Hiss did some of his medical training in the United States at Case Western Reserve in the years after the Kennedy assassination, and he says the autopsy on Kennedy was discussed a lot-- mainly as a cautionary tale, as a lesson on what not to do when performing a postmortem. The autopsy became one more thing that stoked the conspiracy theories.
“关于肯尼迪总统的死亡。”希斯在肯尼迪遇刺后的几年里，在美国凯斯西储大学进行了一些医学培训，他说当时肯尼迪的尸检被讨论得很多——主要是作为反面教材，作为进行尸检时不要做什么的教训。尸检成了加剧阴谋论的又一件事。
So I promised myself that it would never happen in Israel. That if there is some high-profile case I would be called to perform an autopsy, I will do the most accurate thing. And I tried to do it in the prime minister's case and said I don't want, you know, the same claims that the autopsy was not accurate, that there were no photographs, and so on. And they tried to do, you know, everything-- you know, regular things. To act regular.
所以我向自己承诺，这种事绝不会在以色列发生。如果遇到什么高调案件需要我进行尸检，我一定会做到最准确。在总理的案件中我尽力了，我说我不想，你知道，出现同样的声称尸检不准确，没有照片等等之类的言论。他们尝试做，你知道，所有常规的事情。表现得正常。
"Regular" meant Hiss insisted on having both his assistants with him during the Rabin autopsy. One of them was a photographer. It also meant that Hiss described aloud every step he took, dictating it into a tape recorder. His assistant transcribed the notes later that morning.
“正常”意味着希斯坚持在拉宾尸检时让他的两名助手都在场。其中一人是摄影师。这也意味着希斯大声描述了他的每一步操作，口述进了录音机。他的助手第二天早上转录了这些笔记。
Hiss found two bullets in Rabin, one in the lung and the other in the chest, and no exit wounds. The third bullet fired by Amir went through the arm of a bodyguard.
希斯在拉宾身上发现了两颗子弹，一颗在肺部，另一颗在胸部，没有出口伤。阿米尔发射的第三颗子弹穿透了一名保镖的手臂。
There was nothing mysterious, you know? There's nothing complicated.
没有什么神秘的，你知道吗？没什么复杂的。
The bullets that Hiss found inside Rabin were standard hollow points, not the ones Hagai had modified in his shed with the ball bearings after all. Those ended up at the bottom of his brother's magazine.
希斯在拉宾体内发现的子弹是标准的空尖弹，而不是哈盖之后在小屋里用钢珠改装的那种。那些子弹最后留在了他兄弟弹匣的底部。
Do the conspiracy theorists contact you? Do they ever try to--
阴谋论者会联系你吗？他们是否尝试过——
Yes. They call me and, "Do you know that we know that--" I say, "I have nothing to add." It's crazy. It's amazing what is happening. The Israeli believe that there was some kind of conspiracy regarding his death.
是的。他们打电话给我，说：“你知道吗，我们知道……”我说：“我没什么可补充的。”这太疯狂了。发生的事情太惊人了。以色列人相信他的死存在某种阴谋。
We are asking the questions-- very, very simple questions.
我们正在问问题——非常、非常简单的问题。
This is Hillel Weiss. He's a political columnist and one of the early adopters and proselytizers of the conspiracy theories-- also a literature professor emeritus. He's in his 70s, he's got a white beard, very jolly. In the Rabin era, he was on TV a lot, and he's cheerful about why.
这是希勒尔·韦斯。他是政治专栏作家，也是阴谋论的早期采纳者和传教者——也是一位退休文学教授。他七十多岁，留着白胡子，非常快活。在拉宾时代，他经常上电视，他对为什么上电视感到高兴。
When the television want to see a crazy one from the right wing, they  call Hillel Weiss.
当电视节目想找一个右翼的疯子时，他们会找希勒尔·韦斯。
You.
你。
Yes. And I supply them the-- the goods.
是的。我为他们提供……货源。
He lives in the West Bank, in a settlement he helped found nearly 40 years ago. It's called Elkana. He also helped found something else-- a group that calls itself The Public Committee for the Reinvestigation of the Rabin Murder.
他住在约旦河西岸，一个他近40年前帮助建立的定居点。它叫埃尔卡纳。他还帮助创立了别的东西——一个自称为“拉宾谋杀案重新调查公众委员会”的组织。
Well, they think that Rabin himself and his party and all the people that were in the inside circle, they wanted to turn public opinion. Therefore, they make this fake event to defame the right wing.
嗯，他们认为拉宾本人和他的党派以及所有核心圈子里的人，他们想转变公众舆论。因此，他们制造了这个虚假事件来诋毁右翼。
This is the core of Hillel's theory. Rabin himself orchestrated what was supposed to be an attempt on his own life by the right. It was supposed to be a thwarted attempt. The event would create sympathy for Rabin and for Oslo and boost his approval ratings, and it would make the right look bad.
这就是希勒尔理论的核心。拉宾本人策划了所谓的针对他自己的右翼暗杀企图。这本该是一次未遂的暗杀。该事件会为拉宾和奥斯陆协议赢得同情，提高他的支持率，并让右翼看起来很糟糕。
In the fake assassination, as Hillel lays it out, Yigal Amir is either a collaborator or a patsy, and what the country saw on video was Amir firing blanks, not real bullets. Rabin then pretended to fall and was helped into the car and driven away. But then in the car, somehow Rabin dies anyway. And here, the theories get hazy. It's not clear what happened in the car, but whatever happened, it wasn't part of the plan. Inside the car, that's when someone-- or some "they"-- takes charge.
在希勒尔所设想的虚假暗杀中，伊加尔·阿米尔要么是同谋，要么是替罪羊，而全国在视频中看到的是阿米尔发射空包弹，而不是实弹。拉宾随后假装倒下，被扶进车里带走。但在车里，拉宾莫名其妙地死了。在这里，理论变得模糊。不清楚车里发生了什么，但无论发生了什么，这都不在计划之内。在车里，那就是某个人——或者某个“他们”——接管了局势的时候。
You ask me who are "they?" And you ask me if "they" are Shabak.
你问我“他们”是谁？你问我“他们”是不是辛贝特。
Shabak, again, Israel's FBI.
辛贝特，再次强调，是以色列的FBI。
I cannot give any precise answer. The major claim is that Rabin died from a shot to the chest, and not from his back.
我无法给出任何确切的答案。主要的观点是，拉宾死于胸口中弹，而不是背后。
Hillel has some thoughts about what might have led to that shot. Maybe there was a conspiracy within the conspiracy, or maybe Rabin just had a stroke in the car. Maybe it was as simple as that. Because even a stroke, if that's what happened, would have sabotaged the whole story the left was trying to sell. With a stroke, the left would get none of the political advantages of a thwarted assassination. Just a guy in a hospital bed who might not even be able to talk. The only way to salvage the story at that point would be to really kill Rabin-- to shoot him in the chest.
希勒尔对导致那一枪的原因有一些想法。也许阴谋中还有阴谋，或者拉宾只是在车里中风了。也许就这么简单。因为即使是中风——如果发生了的话——也会破坏左翼试图兜售的所有故事。如果是中风，左翼将从这次未遂暗杀中得不到任何政治优势。只是一个可能连话都说不出来的家伙躺在医院病床上。到那时挽救故事的唯一方法就是真的杀死拉宾——向他的胸口开枪。
They have no choice, because it destroys all the story.
他们别无选择，因为这摧毁了整个故事。
So you're saying Rabin decided--
所以你的意思是拉宾决定——
It can be a possibility.
这是一种可能性。
But one possibility-- or a possibility that might be the one that you believe in-- is that Rabin staged his own assassination--
但是一种可能性——或者你相信的那种可能性——是拉宾自导自演了自己的暗杀——
Yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的。
In order to--
为了——
Yes, I'm sure.
是的，我肯定。
In order to improve his popularity and the popularity of the peace process.
为了提高他的受欢迎程度以及和平进程的受欢迎程度。
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
And then got into the car on his own.
然后自己走进了车里。
On his own feet.
靠他自己的双脚。
And then maybe in the car, he had a stroke, you're saying?
然后你说也许在车里，他中风了？
It can be. It can be. It can be that he had a stroke.
可能。可能。可能是他中风了。
Where did the bullets come from?
子弹从哪来的？
The simple idea is that someone killed him.
简单的想法是有人杀了他。
This was the push and pull of the conversation. Some parts of his theory Hillel would deliver in the most emphatic tone you can imagine. About other parts, he would say, "Maybe. I don't know. I'm just asking questions." It's a prerogative of conspiracy theories not to have to answer questions, but just to raise them and keep raising them.
这就是对话的反复推拉。希勒尔以你能想象的最坚定的语气阐述了他理论的某些部分。关于其他部分，他会说：“也许吧。我不知道。我只是提出疑问。”阴谋论的特权就是不必回答问题，只需提出问题并不断提出问题。
But what gives the theories traction-- what makes a lot of people ready to believe them-- is the way Hillel and the other conspiracists connect their story to some real loose ends about the murder that have never been resolved. Details everyone in the country knows. Of course, loose ends happen in murder cases. I've heard that from investigators. Those details, they just take on more significance when it's an assassination. One famous loose end in this case-- at the moment of the assassination, someone in the parking lot yelled, "Blanks!" Or maybe he yelled, "Fake!" or "It's not real!" Witnesses heard all three. Who yelled it and why, that's never been fully resolved. For Hillel, it's evidence that Amir fired blanks.
但让这些理论获得支持——让很多人准备相信它们的原因——是希勒尔和其他阴谋论者将他们的故事与关于谋杀案的一些从未解决的真实悬案联系起来的方式。这些细节全国每个人都知道。当然，谋杀案中常有悬案。我从调查人员那里听到过。当它是一场暗杀时，这些细节只是获得了更多的意义。这个案件中一个著名的悬案——在暗杀的那一刻，停车场里有人喊了“空包弹！”或者也许他喊了“假的！”或“不是真的！”目击者听到了这三种。谁喊的以及为什么，从未完全解决。对于希勒尔来说，这是阿米尔发射空包弹的证据。
A prime minister staging his own assassination, all that cloak and dagger artifice-- Hillel believes that's how committed Rabin was to forcing the Oslo deal. At the time of the assassination, the country was split almost exactly in half between Oslo opponents and Oslo supporters. Hillel was one of the many Israelis who hated Oslo. He thought the slogan from the pro-Oslo political rally, "Yes to peace," was a farce.
一位总理自导自演自己的暗杀，所有那些披风和匕首的伪装——希勒尔相信拉宾对强制通过奥斯陆协议是多么的坚定。在暗杀发生时，该国在奥斯陆反对者和奥斯陆支持者之间几乎各占一半。希勒尔是许多憎恨奥斯陆协议的以色列人之一。他认为亲奥斯陆的政治集会口号“支持和平”是一场闹剧。
We felt that Oslo is a total disaster, because it's not peace. It's a mask of peace to annihilate the Jewish state and the Jewish people, like in Holocaust.
我们觉得奥斯陆协议是一场彻底的灾难，因为它不是和平。这是像大屠杀时期一样，为了歼灭犹太国家和犹太人民的和平假面具。
He says "annihilate the state" because Oslo meant giving up parts of the West Bank and Gaza to the Palestinians. That's land Hillel considers sacred to the Jews, and he wrote hundreds of articles against Oslo, by his own estimation-- and in the articles, he went after Rabin.
他说“歼灭国家”是因为奥斯陆协议意味着交出约旦河西岸和加沙的部分地区给巴勒斯坦人。那是希勒尔认为对犹太人神圣的土地，他根据自己的估计写了数百篇文章反对奥斯陆协议——而在文章中，他抨击了拉宾。
I want to say to you something that -- when I wrote the articles, I thought that I'm aiming bullets to the head of Rabin, because those words were so sharp.
我想告诉你一件事——当我写这些文章时，我以为我是在向拉宾的头部瞄准子弹，因为那些词句是如此尖锐。
It was these sorts of articles-- plus the posters, the chants of "Death to Rabin," the whole ugly pile of rhetoric-- that, after the assassination, turned public opinion against the right, especially the religious right, and caused a spike in support for the Oslo deal. Hillel and the others on the right watched this and a logic took hold-- the who-benefits logic that's common to conspiracy theories. If the left benefited from the assassination, maybe the left engineered the assassination.
正是这些文章——加上海报、高喊“拉宾去死”、整堆丑陋的言论——在暗杀之后，将公众舆论转向了反对右翼，特别是宗教右翼，并导致了对奥斯陆协议的支持激增。希勒尔和右翼的其他人在观察这一过程时，逻辑占据了上风——即阴谋论中常见的“谁受益”逻辑。如果左翼从暗杀中受益，也许是左翼策划了暗杀。
But the benefit was temporary. Within six months, the left was out of power, the right was in power, and Oslo was on its way to being gutted. And that's when the arguments really began.
但这种利益是暂时的。六个月内，左翼失去了权力，右翼掌权，奥斯陆协议被架空。那时真正的争论才开始。
Today, and for the last 20 years, the Rabin assassination is a club that the right and left continue to beat each other with in a fight over two radically different interpretations of the country's history, its future-- two visions that are irreconcilable. This is a Rabin assassination-related shouting match in the debate right before the most recent election.
今天，以及过去20年里，拉宾暗杀事件一直是左右双方在争论国家历史和未来——两种截然不同且不可调和的愿景时，继续用来攻击对方的棍子。这是一场在最近一次选举前的辩论中与拉宾暗杀相关的口角。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
From the left's perspective, Rabin's assassination is the moment that completely reshaped Israel's history. It killed off the last, best chance for peace between Israels and Palestinians, and Yigal Amir has got to be one of the most successful assassins anywhere. One person told us, "Look, when Lincoln was murdered, it didn't bring back slavery. When Martin Luther King, Jr. was killed, civil rights continued. But after Rabin's murder, Oslo unraveled, settlements expanded, and the right has been in power for most of the past 20 years. I've heard people on the left call the assassination a coup."
从左翼的角度来看，拉宾的暗杀彻底重塑了以色列的历史。它扼杀了以色列和巴勒斯坦之间和平的最后且最好的机会，而伊加尔·阿米尔一定是任何地方最成功的刺客之一。有人告诉我们：“看，林肯被谋杀时，并没有带回奴隶制。马丁·路德·金被杀时，民权运动还在继续。但在拉宾被谋杀后，奥斯陆协议瓦解，定居点扩张，在过去20年的大部分时间里，右翼一直掌权。”我听过左翼的人称这场暗杀为政变。
The right is incensed by that version of events. They tell a very different story-- that the peace process had no chance anyway, Arafat was never gonna do what  he promised. A wave of Palestinian suicide bombings after Rabin's death turned the country against the peace process. In short, Oslo was a fantasy and leftists have been sore losers ever since. They've lost almost every election for the past 20 years, and to make themselves feel better, they bring up the Rabin assassination and try to stain the entire right with that horrible act. A lot of people on the right are offended by the suggestion that Yigal Amir acted on their behalf.
右翼对这一事件版本感到愤怒。他们讲述了一个完全不同的故事——和平进程本来就没机会，阿拉法特永远不会兑现他的承诺。拉宾死后的一波巴勒斯坦自杀式爆炸袭击使该国反对和平进程。简而言之，奥斯陆协议是一个幻想，左翼分子从那时起就是输不起的人。过去20年里，他们几乎输掉了每一场选举，为了让自己好受点，他们提起拉宾暗杀事件，试图用那可怕的行为玷污整个右翼。右翼的许多人对伊加尔·阿米尔代表他们行事的说法感到冒犯。
We heard again and again in interviews with Israelis on the right and devout Israelis, "Yigal Amir was not from our camp. He was a loner. He lived in Herzliya. He's not a settler. He wore a different kind of kippah--" kippah meaning yarmulke or skullcap. "We don't condone what he did. He is not one of us." That's why we were taken aback when an orthodox man named Menachem Lazar, who comes from a very right-wing background, told us Amir didn't seem foreign to him at all-- just the opposite.
我们在采访以色列右翼和虔诚的以色列人时反复听到：“伊加尔·阿米尔不是我们阵营的。他是个独行侠。他住在赫兹利亚。他不是定居者。他戴着不同款式的基帕（kippah）——”基帕意为小圆帽。 “我们不宽恕他所做的。他不是我们的一员。”这就是为什么当一个名叫梅纳赫姆·拉扎尔的、来自极右翼背景的东正教男子告诉我们，阿米尔对他来说一点都不陌生——恰恰相反，我们感到惊讶。
But the moment I heard on the TV about the assassination, my first instinct was to take off my kippah.
但我从电视上听到暗杀消息的那一刻，我的第一直觉是摘下我的基帕。
To take it off your head.
从你的头上摘下来。
Yeah, because I-- I knew the religious origins of the murder, the religious justification of the assassination. And I told myself, I can't be a part of it. I don't want to be a part of it.
是的，因为我——我知道这起谋杀案的宗教根源，暗杀的宗教合理化。我告诉自己，我不能成为它的一部分。我不想成为它的一部分。
Menachem is tall and soft-spoken. He says, after the assassination, he heard things in private, in the synagogue he attends and at gatherings with friends, that disturbed him and that most Israelis would never say publicly.
梅纳赫姆很高，说话轻声细语。他说，暗杀后，他在私下里，在他参加的犹太教堂和朋友聚会上听到了一些令他不安的事情，大多数以色列人永远不会公开说出这些话。
I remember people saying, "Well, that's good."
我记得有人说：“嗯，那很好。”
About-- that he was assassinated.
关于——他被暗杀这件事。
"He had it coming. That's good." I saw people that were glad that he was assassinated.
“他罪有应得。那很好。”我看到有人为他被暗杀感到高兴。
Menachem didn't take off his kippah in the end. He had young kids and he knew it would confuse them. We were interviewing Menachem because he's a pollster and we wanted to talk to him about the numbers, the fact that a third of Israelis believe there was some kind of conspiracy or cover-up around the assassination. And among people who identify as right-wing, at least 50% doubt Yigal Amir did it. Menachem is a psychologist by training. He was working as a psychologist for the army when Rabin was assassinated, and he said he's never been surprised by the high number of Israelis who believe in the conspiracy theories.
梅纳赫姆最终没有摘下基帕。他有年幼的孩子，他知道这会让孩子们困惑。我们采访梅纳赫姆是因为他是一名民意测验专家，我们想和他谈谈数据，即有三分之一的以色列人相信暗杀背后存在某种阴谋或掩盖行为。在自认为是右翼的人群中，至少50%怀疑是伊加尔·阿米尔干的。梅纳赫姆受过心理学训练。拉宾被暗杀时，他正在军队担任心理学家，他说，对大量相信阴谋论的以色列人他从不感到惊讶。
Yeah, most of this part comes from the orthodox Israelis, and the orthodox Jews in Israel were blamed for the murder. I'm only saying that when reality is too, um-- too threatening or too-- it's hard for you to accept what happened. So you come up with the conspiracy theories about JFK, about September 11, and about Rabin. The prime minister was killed. He was killed by a religious Jew. I can't accept that, or I have to find an alternative explanation. And they came up with the conspiracy.
是的，这大部分来自东正教以色列人，而以色列的东正教犹太人被指责为谋杀案的罪魁祸首。我只是说，当现实太……太具有威胁性或太……让你难以接受发生的事情时。所以你编造了关于肯尼迪、关于9·11和关于拉宾的阴谋论。总理被杀了。他是被一个虔诚的犹太人杀的。我无法接受这一点，或者我必须找到另一种解释。于是他们想出了阴谋论。
It's probably clear by now, I've always been skeptical of the conspiracy theories. There's just so much evidence proving Yigal Amir killed Rabin. But, in reporting on the assassination, I did have one moment when I thought, "Yikes, maybe." It was during an interview with Rabin's daughter, Dalia, who is not a conspiracist and not from the right side of the political map, and yet there was this thing that made even her wonder. And she agreed to talk about it, but she didn't want to be recorded.
到目前为止很清楚，我一直对阴谋论持怀疑态度。有太多的证据证明伊加尔·阿米尔杀了拉宾。但是，在报道这起暗杀事件时，我有过一瞬间想到：“哇，也许吧。”那是在采访拉宾的女儿达莉亚时，她不是阴谋论者，也不是来自右翼阵营，但有一件事甚至让她也产生了怀疑。她同意谈论这件事，但不想被录音。
It had to do with the idea that what killed Rabin was a bullet to the front. Most of the conspiracy theories hinge on that idea. Remember, Yigal Amir shot Rabin from behind. The pathologist concluded that he was hit by just two bullets, both in the back, no exit wounds. But when I met Dalia in her office, she told me that even she began to have some doubts. She had a box brought up to her office that contained everything her father was wearing on the night of the assassination, down to the socks and shoes. She opened the box and pulled out the shirt her father wore. She held it in that way that you hold something that you don't want to touch, with the tips of her fingers. It's a white collared shirt, entirely encrusted in blood, and ripped in several places. Doctors tore it in the emergency room.
这与拉宾是被正面击中的想法有关。大多数阴谋论都建立在这个想法上。记住，伊加尔·阿米尔是从后面射杀拉宾的。病理学家断定他只被两颗子弹击中，都在背部，没有出口伤。但在达莉亚的办公室见到她时，她告诉我，甚至她也开始产生一些怀疑。她让人把一个箱子送到办公室，里面装满了她父亲暗杀那天穿的所有东西，直到袜子和鞋子。她打开箱子，拿出了她父亲穿的衬衫。她以那种你不想触摸某物时的方式拿着它，用指尖捏着。这是一件白色领子衬衫，完全被血浸透，多处撕裂。医生在急诊室里把它撕开了。
Dalia showed me the two bullet holes in the back of the shirt, and then she flipped the shirt over and pointed to a hole in the front as well. It was perfectly round, smaller than a dime, on the lower-left side, near the buttons. The undershirt Rabin wore that night also had a hole in the front. On her desk, Dalia carefully laid the undershirt inside the shirt, the way it would hang on her father, and the holes lined up. And I have to say, there in her office, with these bloody shirts on the table, it stopped me short. It's a lot harder to dismiss something you see with your own eyes, something the daughter of the murdered man worries about. We just stood there and stared at it.
达莉亚给我看了衬衫背部的两个弹孔，然后她翻过衬衫，也指出了正面的一个孔。它非常圆，比一角硬币还小，在左下侧，靠近纽扣。拉宾那天晚上穿的内衣正面也有一个洞。在她的办公桌上，达莉亚小心翼翼地把内衣放在衬衫里面，就像她父亲穿的那样，孔洞对齐了。我必须说，在那间办公室里，桌子上摆着这些血淋淋的衬衫，让我停了下来。当你亲眼看到某件事时，很难轻易否定它，特别是连被害人的女儿都为此担忧的事。我们就那样站在那里盯着它看。
Dalia told me the clothes sat in Israel's National Archive for a decade after the murder. Then in 2005, there was an Israeli TV documentary about the hole in the front of the shirt. It's inconclusive, but it ends with ominous music and a voiceover about how this third hole, quote, "Raises the possibility of an additional bullet."
达莉亚告诉我，这些衣服在谋杀后在以色列国家档案馆里放了十年。然后到了2005年，有一部以色列电视纪录片讲述了衬衫正面的那个洞。它没有结论，但结尾伴随着不祥的音乐和关于这个第三个洞如何，引用：“提出了额外子弹的可能性”的画外音。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
The TV show popularized the notion that Rabin was actually shot in the front-- you hear that a lot now in Israel-- and it turned the shirt into Exhibit A for the conspiracists, maybe their single most important piece of proof.
那部电视节目普及了拉宾实际上是被正面射击的观点——你现在在以色列经常听到——它把这件衬衫变成了阴谋论者的“证据A”，也许是他们最重要的一份证据。
Dalia did not want to have the clothes examined herself. She's a public figure and she worried that just the act of her getting them tested would fuel the conspiracy theories. So I asked her if she would let me take the shirt to the US, away from the politics, to have it tested, and she said yes.
达莉亚自己不想让人检查这些衣服。她是一个公众人物，她担心仅仅是她进行检测的行为就会助长阴谋论。所以我问她是否愿意让我把衬衫带到美国，远离政治，进行检测，她同意了。
Dan Ephron and Nancy Updike. Coming up, Dan puts the bloody clothing of the dead prime minister into a wheelie bag and brings it to America to be tested. The results in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
丹·埃夫隆和南希·厄普代克。接下来，丹把已故总理的血衣放进一个滑轮袋里带到美国进行检测。在一会后的芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- "The Night in Question." If you're just tuning in, we're hearing the story of the night that Israeli prime minister Yitzak Rabin was assassinated 20 years ago. The anniversary of his  death is in two weeks. It's November 4, 1995. Nancy Updike and Dan Ephron are telling the story, and when we left off before the break, Dan was taking Rabin's bloody clothing from the night of the murder to the United States, with the blessing of Rabin's daughter, to see if the hole in the front of Rabin's shirt was caused by a bullet, which is something that most of the conspiracy theories about the assassination hinge on. OK, here's Dan.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——“被质疑的那一夜”。如果你刚开始收听，我们正在讲述以色列总理伊扎克·拉宾20年前被暗杀的那晚的故事。他去世的纪念日就在两周后。那是1995年11月4日。南希·厄普代克和丹·埃夫隆正在讲述这个故事，在休息前我们讲到，丹带着拉宾遇刺当晚的血衣来到美国，并得到拉宾女儿的祝福，去看看衬衫正面的洞是不是由子弹造成的，这是关于暗杀的大多数阴谋论所依赖的点。好的，接下来是丹。
I flew to Phoenix, and then drove to Carefree, Arizona, a town of about 3,000 people in the desert. Big, open sky, rock formations, lots of cacti. I pulled up to a one-story house early in the morning.
我飞往菲尼克斯，然后开车去了亚利桑那州的Carefree，一个沙漠里约有3000人的小镇。天空广阔，岩层，大量的仙人掌。清晨我驶向一栋平房。
Am I at the right place?
我找对地方了吗？
Yeah, you're at the right place.
是的，你找对地方了。
Lucien Haag-- he goes by Luke-- came out to greet me. He's in his 70s, in brown pants and short sleeve dress shirt and glasses. He works from an office attached to his house. His wife Sandi is there.
卢西安·哈格——他自称卢克——出来迎接我。他70多岁，穿着棕色裤子、短袖正装衬衫和眼镜。他在家里的附设办公室工作。他的妻子桑迪也在那里。
Do you like tea?
你喜欢喝茶吗？
Luke is kind of famous among forensic examiners. He's written a book that's a go-to manual in the profession and he's worked on some big cases over the years, including the shootout at Ruby Ridge and the murder of Rabbi Meir Kahane. He also reexamined the ballistics of the Kennedy assassination for an episode of NOVA not too long ago. He has a lab and an indoor firing range. He collects all kinds of things-- there's a periodic table in Russian on one of the walls. And he's got bullets from all kinds of guns. He picks out one to show me.
卢克在法医鉴定专家中很出名。他写过一本该专业的指导手册，多年来参与过一些大案，包括红宝石岭枪战和梅厄·卡汉内拉比的谋杀案。不久前，他还为NOVA的一集节目重新检查了肯尼迪暗杀案的弹道学。他有一个实验室和一个室内射击场。他收集各种各样的东西——墙上有一张俄文的元素周期表。他有来自各种枪支的子弹。他挑出一个给我看。
--very unusual. That's the kind of bullet that killed Kennedy. And you can see it's very, very long. It's basically a cylinder. Very atypical.
——非常不寻常。那就是杀死肯尼迪的那种子弹。你可以看到它非常、非常长。它基本上是一个圆柱体。非常典型。
He says Lee Harvey Oswald bought the rifle he used in the assassination for $13 and, he concludes--
他说李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德花了13美元买了他在暗杀中使用的步枪，他得出结论——
It's not a great gun, but it will kill you-- as we know.
这不是一把好枪，但它会杀死你——正如我们所知。
Luke places my wheelie bag on the countertop in the lab and begins unpacking the clothes, starting with the jacket.
卢克把我的滑轮袋放在实验室的台面上，开始拆开衣服，从夹克开始。
Boy. Israeli paramedics are even worse-- or more thorough, I guess I should say-- than ours. They just cut the bejeebers out of this.
天哪。以色列医护人员甚至比我们的更糟——或者说更彻底。他们简直把这件衣服切得不成样了。
I'm gonna condense the six hours of forensic testing into about three minutes. But, just so you know how thorough he was, Luke tested every garment Rabin wore on his upper body the night of the assassination. He looked at all the holes and he did comparison tests on other parts of the garment. But I had come for the shirt-- and specifically, the hole in the front.
我会把六小时的法医测试浓缩成大约三分钟。为了让你知道他有多彻底，卢克测试了拉宾在暗杀当晚穿着的所有上半身衣物。他检查了所有的孔洞，并对服装的其他部分进行了对比测试。但我为那件衬衫而来——特别是正面的那个洞。
Whoa. I'm very surprised. "Whoa" doesn't mean "Oh my god, it's a bullet hole." "Whoa" just means "That's a very clean, sharply-defined hole."
哇。我很惊讶。“哇”并不意味着“哦我的天，这是一个弹孔。”“哇”只是意味着“这是一个非常干净、轮廓分明的洞。”
You know, it almost looks like a, uh-- like a hole punch.
你知道，它看起来几乎就像一个，呃——像个打孔器打的。
Yeah. You certainly brought something different and very interesting. And no judgments or pronouncements to make, other than this is different.
是的。你确实带来了一些不同且非常有趣的东西。我不做评判或声明，除了说这确实很特别。
Luke is looking for three things-- traces of soot, copper, and lead. Bullets leave particles as they pass through fabric. They tend to cling for decades or more, especially with polyester, and Rabin's shirt was 55% cotton, 45% polyester. He photographs the hole with an infrared filter and looks at it through a microscope. He sprays the area and does chemical tests. Everything is negative-- no soot, no copper, no lead. And along the way, Luke has ruled out another possibility-- a cigarette burn. Rabin was a heavy smoker.
卢克在寻找三样东西——烟灰、铜和铅的痕迹。子弹穿过织物时会留下微粒。它们倾向于附着几十年甚至更久，特别是聚酯纤维，而拉宾的衬衫是55%棉，45%聚酯纤维。他用红外滤镜拍摄了这个孔，并通过显微镜观察。他喷洒该区域并进行化学测试。结果全是阴性的——没有烟灰，没有铜，没有铅。在此过程中，卢克排除了另一种可能性——烟头灼伤。拉宾是个烟瘾很大的人。
Luke suggests one last thing. He wants to fire a new bullet into a swath of Rabin's shirt to see if the hole it makes-- a genuine bullet hole-- looks anything like the mystery hole. He gets out the scissors.
卢克提出了最后一件事。他想往拉宾衬衫的一块布料上射入一颗新子弹，看看它造成的洞——一个真正的弹孔——看起来是否像那个神秘的洞。他拿出了剪刀。
So for the record, with a pair of sharp scissors, I'm cutting out about a-- oh, about a three-inch square--
所以为了记录，用一把锋利的剪刀，我剪下了一个——哦，大约三英寸的正方形——
Luke then said a sentence I've never heard before-- "I think I've got a fresh block of tissue simulant in the garage." He left the lab and came back with a big, brown rectangle of something that was both squishy and firm.
卢克接着说了一句我以前从未听过的话——“我想我在车库里有一块新鲜的组织模拟物。”他离开了实验室，带着一个既柔软又坚固的大棕色长方体回来了。
This behaves similar to soft tissue. If you push into it-- if I push into you or a fat guy like me, it's gonna feel about the same.
这表现得类似于软组织。如果你按进去——如果我按你，或者像我这样的胖子，感觉会差不多。
So the block is a stand-in for human flesh. Luke taped the patch of shirt to the block. We went to his range and then he fired a bullet at the patch. I didn't record the sound because I worried it would blow out the recording equipment, which I don't own. Luke shot from up close. As we figured it, just about any scenario where Rabin was shot in the front would mean he was shot at close range.
所以这块东西是人肉的替身。卢克把衬衫补丁粘在块状物上。我们去了他的射击场，然后他向补丁开了一枪。我没有录音，因为担心这会损坏我没有所有权的录音设备。卢克近距离射击。按照我们的理解，拉宾被正面射击的任何场景都意味着他是近距离被射击的。
Luke then examined the new hole under the microscope. He compared the patch to the mystery hole, looked up from the lens, and that was it. The two looked nothing alike.
卢克随后在显微镜下检查了新产生的洞。他把补丁和那个神秘的洞做了比较，从镜头里抬头看了一眼，就这样。这两者看起来一点也不像。
But it just can't be a bullet. I mean, there's just nothing there to support that notion. I've been looking at bullet holes for 47 years or so. I shoot things for a living-- I mean, almost daily I'm shooting something. Everything I see says it's something other than a bullet.
但这根本不可能是子弹。我的意思是，根本没有东西支持这个概念。我观察弹孔已经47年左右了。我以射击东西为生——我的意思是，我几乎每天都在射击东西。我看到的一切都表明它不是子弹造成的。
So, it's not a bullet hole. That's the important part. Rabin was not shot in the front. Dalia was relieved when I let her know.
所以，它不是弹孔。这是重要的部分。拉宾不是从正面被射击的。当我告诉达莉亚时，她松了一口气。
The cause of the hole will probably remain one of those loose ends. Maybe someone tampered with the shirt while it sat for years in the archives. Luke speculated that the hole was created by a doctor during the chaos at the hospital, maybe with some medical instrument while they were trying to save his life.
那个洞的原因可能会成为这些悬案之一。也许有人在档案馆里放了多年时篡改了衬衫。卢克推测这个洞是医生在医院混乱期间造成的，也许是在他们试图挽救他生命时用的某种医疗器械。
I ran down all sorts of other disputed facts from the night of the assassination. I talked to Shabak officers, the investigators, the prosecutor. The only other thing I want to report to you is the conversation I had with Rabin's driver from that night. Remember that most of the conspiracy theories say Rabin was actually killed in the car, possibly by a mysterious additional person-- not the driver, not the bodyguard, someone else.
我排查了暗杀之夜所有其他有争议的事实。我谈到了辛贝特官员、调查人员、检察官。我唯一想向你报告的另一件事是我和拉宾当晚的司机进行的谈话。记住，大多数阴谋论说拉宾实际上是在车里被杀的，可能是一个神秘的额外人员——不是司机，不是保镖，而是别人。
The driver, Menachem Damti, is listed in the country directory, so we called him up one morning and he said, "Sure, come over this afternoon."
司机梅纳赫姆·达姆蒂在国家目录上有记录，所以我们有一天早上给他打了电话，他说：“当然，今天下午过来吧。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
He's 66 years old, very fit, a few months away from his pension. He was in gym shorts when we went over. A large percentage of Israelis at any given moment are dressed like they're about to go to the beach or just got back from the beach. He lives in a modest apartment. He was a driver for three decades for political leaders from both parties. He's got a wall in his kitchen covered in framed photos of him with the people he drove for-- several Israeli prime ministers, also Bill Clinton, Jimmy Carter, Anwar Sadat. Menachem does a pretty spot on impression of Rabin telling him from the backseat, in his taciturn way, "Menachem, nice maneuver."
他66岁，身体非常健康，离养老还有几个月。我们过去时他穿着运动短裤。在任何时候，很大一部分以色列人穿着都像正要或刚从海滩回来。他住在一个朴素的公寓里。他为政治领袖当了三十年司机，跨越了两个党派。他的厨房墙上贴满了照片，照片里是他和曾为之开车的政要们——几位以色列总理，还有比尔·克林顿、吉米·卡特、安瓦尔·萨达特。梅纳赫姆模仿拉宾从后座以沉默寡言的方式告诉他，“梅纳赫姆，漂亮的机动。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
What Menachem remembers about that night, after jumping into the driver's seat, is Rabin's bodyguard, Yoram Rabin, lifting Rabin into the backseat, diving in after him, and then he yells to Menachem, "Go to the hospital, quickly!" Next, Menachem does a quick move he's been taught to make the car doors slam shut.
梅纳赫姆关于那个晚上记得的是，在跳进驾驶座后，拉宾的保镖约拉姆·拉宾把拉宾扶进后座，随后自己也跳了进去，然后他向梅纳赫姆大喊：“快去医院！”接下来，梅纳赫姆做了一个他被教过的快速动作，让车门砰地关上。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
The drill is, in order to close the doors, you press on the gas, and then quickly press on the brakes, and then give gas. And the force of the sudden acceleration closes the door, slams the doors. This was-- Menachem is mentioning this because he himself has heard about these conspiracy theories. One of them is who slammed the door-- ostensibly, mysteriously, because there is no one. And this was kind of the evidence that there was someone inside the car in addition to Rabin and Damti and Rabin.
训练是这样的：为了关门，你踩油门，然后快速踩刹车，再给油。突然加速的力量关上了车门，砰地撞上车门。这是——梅纳赫姆提到这个是因为他自己也听说过这些阴谋论。其中之一是谁关的车门——表面上神秘地，因为那里没有人。这成了证据，证明车里除了拉宾、达姆蒂和拉宾之外还有人。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Then Menachem makes a left, which is the wrong way to go to the hospital. There were people and police barricades all around, he was in shock, and he went left. This is another part of the conspiracy theory-- that he intentionally delayed getting to the hospital so that whoever else was supposedly in the car had time to kill Rabin. It's clear as Menachem is talking that going left that night-- his mistake-- galls him.
然后梅纳赫姆向左拐，这是去医院的错误方向。周围都是人和警察路障，他在震惊中向左拐了。这是阴谋论的另一部分——他故意延迟去医院，以便据说在车里的其他人有时间杀死拉宾。当梅纳赫姆说话时很清楚，那天晚上向左拐——他的错误——让他非常懊恼。
I asked Menachem what was happening in the car as he drove. Was it chaotic? Was it loud? Were he and the bodyguard Yoram Rabin shouting or talking to each other? Was Rabin making any noise? He said it was horribly, horribly quiet.
我问梅纳赫姆在他开车时车里发生了什么。混乱吗？吵吗？他和保镖约拉姆·拉宾在争吵或交谈吗？拉宾发出任何声音吗？他说那里安静得可怕。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Um, he remembers hearing a little bit from Rabin-- maybe it was a sigh, maybe it was a word-- but mostly nothing. And whatever he did hear, it was mostly Rabin, the bodyguard, from the backseat. Menachem said, "Is he OK? Resuscitate him. Make sure--" and occasionally asking him, "What's his condition?" And then at some point, Rabin says, "I'm also wounded." And from that point on, it felt like utter despair. Menachem felt like he was alone in the car. He was the only one who was actually capable of doing something.
嗯，他记得从拉宾那里听到了一点点——也许是叹息，也许是一个词——但大多没有声音。无论他听到了什么，大部分是保镖从后座发出的。梅纳赫姆说：“他没事吗？抢救他。确保——”偶尔问他：“他情况如何？”然后拉宾在某个时候说：“我也受伤了。”从那时起，他感到了彻底的绝望。梅纳赫姆觉得他在车里孤身一人。他是唯一一个真正有能力做点什么的人。
What a moment to realize it's just you.
意识到只有你一人在现场的那一刻。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
For 30 years, Menachem had been a driver, and the drill was always that there was a bodyguard sitting next to him. And the bodyguard would say, "You go right here, you go left there. Take this road. Do this." Because everyone had pounced on the shooter and everyone was focused on him, there was no one to come into the car and sit next to Menachem. And it's exactly the way you describe it. He's saying he felt utterly alone, utterly alone.
做了30年司机，演练一直是他身边坐着保镖。保镖会说：“你往这里右拐，往那里左拐。走这条路。做这个。”因为大家都扑向了枪手，所有人的注意力都在他身上，没有人进到车里坐在梅纳赫姆旁边。这和你描述的一模一样。他说他感到无比孤独，无比孤独。
I got a very visceral sense of who Rabin was, what he was in Israel, and what his death meant in the country when we talked to one of his most vocal enemies. This is an activist named Daniella Weiss, no relation to Hillel Weiss. She is right-wing, like Hillel, and her single-minded drive in the last 40 years has been to settle as many Jews as possible in the West Bank as quickly as possible. She helped build one of the early settlements named Kedumim. Now she heads a group that sets up outposts, new settlements built without formal permission from the government. She showed us a map she made when she was mayor of the town.
当我谈到他最直言不讳的敌人之一时，我对拉宾是谁，他在以色列代表什么，他的死在这个国家意味着什么有了非常直观的感受。这是一个名叫丹妮拉·韦斯的激进分子，与希勒尔·韦斯没有关系。她像希勒尔一样是右翼，过去40年里她单一的目标是尽快在约旦河西岸安置尽可能多的犹太人。她帮助建立了名为Kedumim的定居点之一。现在她领导一个组织，建立未经政府正式许可的非法前哨站。她给我们展示了她担任镇长时制作的一张地图。
And I-- I did this with my secretary. We actually pasted all these dots so that we now see all the 250 settlements and outposts.
我——我和我的秘书一起做了这个。我们实际上粘贴了所有这些点，这样我们现在看到了所有250个定居点和前哨站。
Daniella was considered fringe for a long time, but in the steady drift of Israeli politics, the mainstream has come to her. She organized the main election rally of the right wing a few months ago in Tel Aviv. When it was time for Prime Minister Netanyahu to speak, Daniella is the one who took the stage to introduce him. She's a firm believer in conspiracy theories, by the way.
丹妮拉长期以来被认为是边缘人物，但在以色列政治的持续漂移中，主流已经向她靠拢。几个月前，她在特拉维夫组织了右翼的主要选举集会。当轮到内塔尼亚胡总理发言时，是丹妮拉走上台介绍他。顺便说一句，她是阴谋论的坚定信徒。
Talking to Daniella, she's so media savvy, it was like talking to a mind reader sometimes. Before I could even say, "Hey, can you please start that sentence over? A loud truck was going by," she would pause and start the sentence over. We asked her about the Rabin assassination and Daniella was blunt. She knew exactly what it meant for her and her movement-- and for the Oslo deal.
和丹妮拉交谈，她非常懂媒体，有时就像在和一个读心者交谈。在我还没来得及说：“嘿，你能请把那句话重说一遍吗？刚才有卡车经过的声音很大，”她就会停下来重说那句话。我们问她关于拉宾暗杀的事，丹妮拉直言不讳。她确切地知道这对她和她的运动——以及奥斯陆协议意味着什么。
The major thought that crossed my mind was, OK, it's a new time. It's a new era. We will continue-- continue to build the land. I was thinking in historical and political terms.
我脑海中闪过的主要念头是，好吧，这是一个新时代。这是一个新时代。我们将继续——继续建设这片土地。我在历史和政治层面上思考。
Right away that night?
那天晚上立刻就想到了？
Right away, when I heard-- when I heard about the murder. I thought history changed-- that Rabin's plan of withdrawal from here, from Judea and Samaria--
当听到——当听到谋杀案时，我立刻就想到了。我认为历史改变了——拉宾从这里，从犹大和撒马利亚撤出的计划——
Judea and Samaria are what religious Jews call the northern and southern parts of the West Bank.
犹大和撒马利亚是虔诚犹太人对约旦河西岸北部和南部地区的称呼。
--from Judea and Samaria came to a stop and a new era opened for us. And from the day-to-day, the chances of removing us from here get lower and lower.
——从犹大和撒马利亚撤出的计划停止了，一个新时代为我们开启。从日常来看，把我们从这里驱逐的机会变得越来越小。
We were talking to Danielle in her living room and she told us she has a plaque outside, built into the wall around her house, commemorating the founding of Kedumim, and it quotes Rabin.
我们在丹妮拉的客厅里交谈，她告诉我们她在她房子的围墙外有一块牌匾，纪念Kedumim的成立，上面引用了拉宾的话。
Can we go look at this plaque right now?
我们现在能去看看那块牌匾吗？
Of course. Right now. Naturally.
当然。现在就去。很自然。
We walked out her front door, down the path through her yard, around to the right, and down the hill a bit. Kedumim is a lush, well-tended, sunny, suburban-looking place, like a lot of the oldest settlements. The plaque says the quote is from the minutes of a cabinet meeting back from when Rabin was prime minister the first time in 1975 and he had to decide what to do about Daniella Weiss and others who had taken over this hill in the West Bank, this hill in front of us. It's pretty well surrounded by Palestinian towns. Every time the Israeli army removed them, they went back-- eight times, the plaque says.
我们走出前门，沿着小径穿过院子，绕到右边，往下走了一段山坡。Kedumim是一个郁郁葱葱、打理得很好、阳光明媚、看起来像郊区的地方，就像许多最古老的定居点一样。牌匾上说，这句引用出自拉宾第一次担任总理时1975年的内阁会议记录，当时他必须决定如何处理丹妮拉·韦斯和其他占领了约旦河西岸这座山的人，就在我们眼前这座山。它被巴勒斯坦城镇相当好地包围着。牌匾上写着，以色列军队每次把他们赶走，他们就回来——一共八次。
I like to show this quotation from Yitzhak Rabin because I find it very much encouraging for the future. Because people tell us, OK, you'll see. For instance, today, the world will boycott you. Nobody will buy things that are produced in the settlement. And there is this obstacle and that obstacle. So I always refer people to Rabin's declaration.
我喜欢展示这句来自伊扎克·拉宾的引用，因为我觉得它对未来非常令人鼓舞。因为人们告诉我们，好吧，你会看到的。例如，今天，全世界会抵制你们。没人会买定居点生产的东西。这里有这个障碍，那里有那个障碍。所以我总是参考拉宾的声明。
She reads from the plaque.
她读着牌匾。
"The words of Yitzhak Rabin, the Prime Minister, to the members of the government." [SPEAKING HEBREW]
“伊扎克·拉宾总理对政府成员说的话。”[希伯来语发言]
The quote is short. Rabin said, about Daniella and the others, "Let them enter Camp Kadum, and after three weeks, they'll all go home." His thinking was, no houses, no electricity, no water, no toilets-- if we call their bluff and leave them there, these people are not gonna stick it out. The dismissiveness was typical of Rabin dealing with the settlers. He didn't like them and he didn't hide it. He called them a cancer in the body of Israeli democracy. He saw them as fringe, especially compared to him. His political party had held power for decades. They founded the country. Rabin was a general. He'd won the Six Day War. He was Israel. And he was utterly secular, completely unmoved by the spiritual attachment religious Jews feel toward the West Bank. To him, the settlers were an irritant.
引用很短。关于丹妮拉和其他人，拉宾说：“让他们进入卡杜姆营地，三周后，他们都会回家。”他的想法是，没有房子、没有电力、没有水、没有厕所——如果我们戳穿他们的虚张声势，把他们留在那里，这些人是不会坚持下去的。这种不屑一顾是拉宾对待定居者的典型态度。他不喜欢他们，也没有隐藏这一点。他称他们为以色列民主体制中的癌症。他把他们视为边缘人物，尤其是与他相比。他的政党已经掌权了几十年。他们建立了国家。拉宾是一位将军。他赢得了六日战争。他就是以色列。而且他完全是世俗的，对虔诚的犹太人对约旦河西岸的精神依恋完全无动于衷。对他来说，定居者是令人恼火的。
Well, it was a big mistake on his side. From my point of view, I'm glad he made this mistake.
嗯，这是他那边的巨大错误。从我的角度来看，我很高兴他犯了这个错误。
That he underestimated the settlers, the settlement movement.
他低估了定居者，定居者运动。
Had he estimated it properly, he would have blocked it.
如果他能正确估计，他就会阻止它。
Oslo was Rabin's do-over, his attempt to block the settlements the way he failed to do in 1975. And Daniella is one of the few right-wing Israelis we talked to who says openly, "We won. After Rabin died, the path toward our vision of the future was clearer than it ever was before. And we've been building settlements since then. We won the land and we won the politics." Today, only 15% of the country identifies as left wing. The left is the fringe.
奥斯陆协议是拉宾的补救机会，是他试图阻止定居点的方式，就像他在1975年没能做到的那样。丹妮拉是我们谈过的少数公开表示“我们赢了”的右翼以色列人之一。在拉宾去世后，通往我们未来愿景的道路比以往任何时候都更清晰。从那时起我们一直在建设定居点。我们赢得了土地，我们赢得了政治。今天，只有15%的以色列人认同自己是左翼。左翼是边缘。
Here in America, lots of us think it's a tough, complicated situation over there. There's violence, there's anger, there's mistrust, but somehow this is going to work out eventually. In the end, the Israelis will give up land. In the end, Palestinian violence will subside. They will have their own state. Somehow, this is all going to happen. But in the 20 years since for Rabin's death, it hasn't happened. And it's not getting more likely. It's getting less likely.
在这里的美国，我们很多人认为那是一个艰难、复杂的情况。有暴力，有愤怒，有不信任，但某种程度上这最终会解决。最终，以色列人会放弃土地。最终，巴勒斯坦的暴力会平息。他们会有自己的国家。某种程度上，这一切都会发生。但在拉宾去世后的20年里，这并没有发生。而且发生的可能性并没有变大。它变得越来越不可能。
There's a letter Hagai, the assassin's brother, wrote from prison sometime after the assassination. It's a letter where he explains why he and his brother decided to kill Rabin. And he puts the assassination in the context of the long arc of Jewish history. He already knows what it means for Israel. He writes, "According to Judaism, killing a king is profoundly significant. It affects the entire nation and alters its destiny." Hagai has no patience for the conspiracists. They attribute the murder to someone else, which means they deny him and his brother the credit for an act the Amir brothers knew at the time would save Israel. Now, 20 years later, they feel vindicated.
刺客的兄弟哈盖在暗杀后不久曾从狱中写过一封信。他在信中解释了为什么他和他的兄弟决定杀死拉宾。他把暗杀放在了犹太历史的长河中。他已经知道这对以色列意味着什么。他写道：“根据犹太教，杀害君王意义深远。它影响整个国家并改变其命运。”哈盖对阴谋论者没有耐心。他们把谋杀归咎于别人，这意味着他们否认了他和他的兄弟因一项阿米尔兄弟当时就知道会拯救以色列的行为而应得的赞誉。现在，20年后，他们感到平反了。
And as we were interviewing Hagai sitting in his front yard, we had a moment that made us realize what a weird disconnect he and his brother live every day. We're sitting there talking and we notice that something was up with his mother, Geula. She was sort of hovering nearby. She offered us water, asked if we wanted to sit inside. She was very welcoming. And then she just stayed outside, within earshot, clearly listening, doing what seemed like make-work in the yard. It was after 9:00 at night. And at some point, she jumped into the conversation from the sidelines and said to her son, "And you-- tell the truth. Don't hide anything."
当我们采访坐在前院的哈盖时，我们有一个瞬间意识到他和他的兄弟每天都活在一种多么奇怪的脱节中。我们坐在那里交谈时，注意到他的母亲盖拉有点不对劲。她一直在附近徘徊。她请我们喝水，问我们想不想坐到屋里去。她非常热情。然后她就一直待在外面，在听力范围内，显然在听，做着看起来像是院子里的杂活。那时已经是晚上9点多了。在某个时候，她从边上加入对话，对她的儿子说：“还有你——说实话。不要隐瞒任何事情。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
"Tell the truth." She's saying that to her son. Even his own mother believes the conspiracy theories. Maybe someone else killed Rabin. Maybe they set up her sons to take the fall. Maybe her own sons aren't telling her the full truth. Geula doesn't come over. She just stays off to the side. But she starts arguing with Hagai about what happened on the night of the assassination. Danny and I are barely in the conversation at all-- it's just the two of them talking to each other with Danny sometimes translating-- and they get into the nitty-gritty of the night. She starts talking about the bus Yigal Amir took to the rally where he shot Rabin. She's saying, "How hard would it have been for a pickpocket to have taken the gun and switched the bullets for blanks?"
“说实话。”她对她的儿子那样说。连他的母亲也相信阴谋论。也许是别人杀了拉宾。也许他们陷害了她的儿子们。也许她自己的儿子们没有告诉她全部真相。盖拉没有过来。她只是待在一边。但她开始和哈盖争论暗杀之夜发生的事情。丹尼和我几乎没有参与对话——只是他们两人在交谈，丹尼有时在翻译——他们谈到了那个夜晚的细节。她开始谈论伊加尔·阿米尔乘公交车去他枪杀拉宾的集会。她说：“如果一个小偷拿走了枪并把子弹换成空包弹，这会有多难？”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Hagai says, "It would have been very hard." He says, "Yigal used to keep his gun between his belt and his body, the same way I do. You'd feel it if someone tried to take it out."
哈盖说：“这会非常难。”他说：“伊加尔习惯把枪放在腰带和身体之间，和我一样。如果有人试图拿走它，你会感觉到的。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Geula says, "Not if it's a professional pickpocket. Their skill is stunning. It's unimaginable. They can take your ear from here and put it over there." She says she talked about all of this to Yigal and he got mad at her. He said, "Conspiracy this, conspiracy that. You're my mother."
盖拉说：“如果是专业小偷就不是这样了。他们的技术令人惊叹。是无法想象的。他们可以把你的耳朵从这里拿走放到那边去。”她说她和伊加尔谈过这一切，他被她惹恼了。他说：“什么阴谋这个，阴谋那个。你是我妈。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
She said to him, "Yes, I'm your mother, but I'm not dumb. We have to understand what's going on here." She goes on, "Of course Yigal confessed. They put you in a position where you have to confess."
她对他说：“是的，我是你妈，但我又不傻。我们必须搞清楚这里发生了什么。”她继续说：“当然伊加尔会招供。他们把你放在一个不得不招供的位置。”
Hagai says, "The confession has nothing to do with it. He fired his gun. Let's say that if Rabin hadn't died, if he'd only been crippled, then OK. But Yigal took into account that Rabin might die. He shot him in the back."
哈盖说：“供词与此无关。他开了枪。我们假设如果拉宾没死，如果他只是残废了，那也行。但伊加尔考虑到了拉宾可能会死。他是从背后射击的。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语发言]
Geula eventually went back inside. Hagai told us that the problem with the conspiracy theories is that they take away the whole ideological statement they were trying to make by killing Rabin, the clear message that Oslo was terrible and that Yigal Amir acted on what he saw as his religious obligation to stop Rabin. Yigal Amir, in his interrogation with policeman Moti Naftali, said he felt he had to kill Rabin before a crazy person did it. He said if a crazy person killed Rabin, it wouldn't have the right impact. The message would have been lost.
盖拉最终回到了屋里。哈盖告诉我们，阴谋论的问题在于它们剥夺了他们通过杀死拉宾所试图做的整个意识形态声明，即奥斯陆协议是可怕的，以及伊加尔·阿米尔基于他认为阻止拉宾是他的宗教义务而行事的信息。伊加尔·阿米尔在接受警察莫蒂·纳夫塔利审讯时说，他觉得他必须在疯子下手前杀死拉宾。他说如果疯子杀了拉宾，就不会产生正确的影响。那个信息就会丢失。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Dan Ephron is the author of the book Killing a King-- The Assassination of Yitzhak Rabin and the Remaking of Israel , which comes out this week. Yigal Amir and Hagai Amir have recently come around to the idea that maybe the conspiracy theorists are correct about one thing-- maybe there are loose ends out there that might exonerate Yigal, who's still in prison. They're looking at these now and considering petitioning for a retrial.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。丹·埃夫隆是本周出版的《杀死国王——伊扎克·拉宾暗杀案与以色列的重塑》一书的作者。伊加尔·阿米尔和哈盖·阿米尔最近开始认为，也许阴谋论者在一点上是对的——也许外面确实有一些悬案可能为仍在狱中的伊加尔平反。他们正在审视这些，并考虑申请重审。
[MUSIC - "LINCOLN LIMOUSINE" BY JERRY LEE LEWIS]
[音乐 - 杰瑞·李·刘易斯的《林肯加长轿车》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Other editing help today from Susan Burton, production help from Lilly Sullivan. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is the office coordinator. Research help today from Christopher Swetala. Original music used as scoring all this hour by Merel & Tony. Other musical help today from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis.
好的，我们今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，还有佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。今天的其他编辑帮助来自苏珊·伯顿，莉莉·沙利文提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的业务运营经理。埃尔娜·贝克为我们的节目寻找故事。金伯利·亨德森是办公室协调员。今天的研究帮助来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。本节目所有时段的原创配乐由Merel & Tony制作。今天的其他音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。
Special thanks today to Daniel Estrin, David Blumenfeld, and Shlomo Harnoy of the Sdema Group.
今天特别感谢Sdema集团的丹尼尔·埃斯特林、大卫·布鲁门菲尔德和什洛莫·哈诺伊。
Our website-- thisamericalife.org.
我们的网站——thisamericalife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has been obsessed lately-- obsessed, I tell you-- watching the Israeli edition of Sesame Street. He especially loves this one character on the show who is always asking--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他最近着迷了——我告诉你，着迷了——看以色列版的《芝麻街》。他特别喜欢那个节目里总是问的一个角色——
"Don't you have any cookies?"
“没有饼干吗？”
I'm Ira Glass. Shabbat shalom, everybody. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。安息日平安，大家。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "LINCOLN LIMOUSINE" BY JERRY LEE LEWIS]
[音乐 - 杰瑞·李·刘易斯的《林肯加长轿车》]